Así es que tal Buenas tardes Raúl pues
efectivamente los 12 miembros del Jurado
han recomendado que se dictamine esa
cadena perpetua para Nicolás Cruz
acusado de 17 cargos por homicidio en
primer grado Aparentemente es una
decisión que ha sorprendido a muchos de
los presentes en la sala principalmente
a los padres de esos niños que murieron
en la masacre de principalmente porque
solo han tardado estos miembros del
Jurado siete horas en tomar esta
decisión de que se dictamine cadena
perpetua para Nicolas Cruz hay que
recordar que para que se llegue a un
acuerdo se la decisión Del Jurado debe
ser unánime de acuerdo a las leyes de la
Florida y que recordar también que la
pena capital en Florida es una pena que
lleva instalada desde 1923 que es
Florida es el cuarto estado con
mayores ejecuciones desde
1976 y es una medida muy popular entre
los residentes de Florida por lo tanto
esa esa sorpresa entre muchos de los
presentes pero también entre muchas de
las personas que estaban siguiendo esta
decisión Del Jurado en televisión sean
paralizado todas las conexiones en
televisión para seguir este esta
decisión Del Jurado ante esa sorpresa
hay que recordar que el 14 de febrero de
2018 nicholas Cruz armado con un rifle
de asalto entró en esa escuela de
parkland al norte de Miami matando a 14
alumnos y tres personas del
staff de la escuela